welcome to podcast ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by and by the way it's January 31st
right now tomorrow's February not only
is it Black History Month we do
celebrate that here in the church it's
also love month ok so I'm here to
promote love this month and we're gonna
start right now today Thursday morning
with love ok what's love start with love
starts with a date a drink you go back
to her place and we'll do a little
dancing maybe a glass of wine maybe you
tell us some [ __ ] story you like
cats oh no the [ __ ] you want to save the
world
next thing you know you take you on
these off she's gonna touch your pipe
but it smells like 10 dead [ __ ] dead
dogs of death and your ass don't smell
no better
how you gonna haha you gotta [ __ ]
communicate pick up a Valentine well
this thing he is that's why I hello
she's here you know what how long she
got calm is there a website that'll
provide you a portable bird days you
could put in your bathroom it takes you
10 minutes even if you're not a plumber
you any like me it takes 8 minutes you
know what that means every time you go
home you take a little poop to do aka a
big dirty [ __ ] not only do you scrub
your ass over you dip your nutsack in
that water and rub it nice with the
towel put cream on it very nice gonna
hello does she not come right now and
get 10% off your portable bidet comes
with a 60 day they come in different
colors just go - hello - she Cara this
podcast is all talk brought to you by
after your nuts are clean you want to
look good with your significant other
this Valentine's Day right then check
out me on these matching pair so now
you're clean you're ready to rock it's a
unique fun gift for you and your
Valentine they're perfect what I'm
talking about is me on these me and
these are the most comfortable fun on
these you and your significant other
will ever own
they're made from the softest material
on earth we're talking three times
softer than cotton Melissa to get 20% of
your matching pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee go to me on
these comms last Joey again that's me
undies comm slash Joey this is gonna be
the best Valentine's
that you'll ever give start matching
your bottom half to your better half go
to me on these down slash Joey right now
so you're looking at me going Joey I got
a fresh [ __ ] a new pair on the West
but I ain't got a date ah that's why
uncle Joey loves you the way he does you
know why because if you're trying online
dating chances are you've run into lazy
text messages dead-end conversations
random matches that don't turn into
dates you can't get to know someone just
by looking at that picture I mean look
at me I'm a handsome dude you don't see
me nobody anyway the point I'm trying to
make is he Harley is unlike many other
dating sites he normally take steps that
other dating sites don't in order to
find you the more compatible match why
be single this Valentine's Day right now
go my listeners get a free month of
eHarmony when you sign up for a three
month subscription so right now tonight
you you'd be you'd be going on dates or
two dates a week till God knows when
till June of July enter my code church
at checkout and get one month for free
with a with a three month subscription
alright so I hooked you up I gave you
hello Toshi I gave you me undies and now
I'm getting you a date and I'm finding
you love with harmony doctor alright
who's better than uncle Joey nobody at
the code Church and check out and let's
get this party started
take that meal Lee had some black people
could do English expressions you know
I'm saying how did the song about being
a nasty girl
because Prince was throwing Heat I guess
vali was part of his little stable at
the piano hanging out and he wrote that
song like that was least like he you
started writing a [ __ ] and he just it
was like Michael Jackson 84 he had
Thriller somebody's watching me and he
had something else yeah that's yeah he
was working the ladies by writing songs
and stuff he did that Apollonia only a
guitar along
he's not you what was that snot the
Manic Monday what was the Machine
Eastern she wrote uh-oh he wrote another
dirty song when she hastened let me see
if there was one song kind of Zapata oh
it's like how they did a football thing
to it once someone don't you got the
look you got the look your mom can't
cook you must have I love prints did you
know I never tell you I was invited to a
private party at Paisley Park no 1995 I
was playing at Acme comedy club in
Minneapolis and princes keyboard player
Tommy was a fan of mine because I was
like doing tons of stuff for Comedy
Central at the time and Prince would do
these parties in the summer where he
would jam from like 3:00 in the morning
until 6:00 in the morning it's how he
came up with his tunes and stuff or
worked it out so we went I invited this
other comedian the feature act and he
didn't go oh Mike and the guy when
Prince died he was the first person to
call me and go man I can't believe I
didn't go to that [ __ ] party so it
was one of the best nights of my life
there was only 50 people there and
Prince is walking around the guy gave me
a tour of Paisley Park before the
concert and he had like a sewing room
like with it was like four sewing
machines and all these beautiful fabrics
where they even made his own clothes you
know his recording studio he shot his
own videos there it was like a one-man
hit Art Factory and then in his you know
big room where he the airplane hangar
room where he shot his videos and stuff
he had the stage set up and he wailed
like Hendrix he had that white guitar
that had the little loopy looked like a
musical note and it was his girlfriend
my Ty's birthday and so she like had a
white flowy dress on and she danced
around him and it was magnificent man he
like he wailed for like three hours he
could [ __ ] him Wow
he was better than Hendrix man [ __ ] and
when
and and and then like he's walking
around after the concert he's like right
in front of me he's like two feet in
front of me it took every bit of my
self-control not to grab his perfect
little purple ass and just squeeze it
you know like a turn me ask you what you
were doing there no we took it no no no
no no his dude introduced us ie
I shook his hand and he was a complete
gentleman and he was nice to everybody
that was there it was amazing
it's a great [ __ ] story that's part
of the art and with a little that's all
Los Angeles Aaron's in the back for a
like to see great to smell a healthy
yeah great to see that you're still in
the game
we've lost a lot of soldiers yeah and
we're still plugging away you're still
[ __ ] going overseas I just got back
from Paris last night that's what you
were saying yeah I played this beautiful
theater theater la over ax I like a over
your your life I can't work like over I
don't know how to pronounce it ooh it's
like mauve ah like an over is like
you're your life's work your masterpiece
violence it's great but this theater man
it was beautiful it seats 340 I had 240
there there was balconies place was
built in 1850 and I'm booked back there
October 15th and I want a film it as my
next Netflix special and do you think
yeah so if anybody's thinking about
taking a trip to Paris go on with your
bad self always trying to [ __ ] be in
the game always reinventing yourself
that's it yeah yeah you're a comic to
the young like Tupac said right that's
right well I got a long history with
Paris the first big love of my adult
life was with a Parisian woman I lived
with in San Francisco for seven years
and the first time I went to Paris I was
actually maced pepper spray these guys
tried to mug me and I got away and all
this stepped in [ __ ] there I've done
a lot of things in Paris but your hours
on Morrison's grave so you like it yeah
I like sauntering down the bowl of
with a baguette under my arm I am a
pepper sprayed the no [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts
man oh my god [ __ ] but I never got
peppers played like by a woman law I was
assaulting somebody the guy that had the
big dick in Jersey that there was a guy
when I grew up that he said he was a the
guy from Godfather twos grandson Sylvia
and Godfather - there's a scene where
Michael takes Fredo this underground bar
to see like a semi rape where they tie a
girl up and the guy comes out with a big
dick in a cape and the guy's dick is
like four foot alone but they never show
the dick the director is a very good
director that's when Michael finds out
that Fredo betrays him all the gimme is
the same look at him he looks like
Superman but they never show you the
guy's dick you never even think about it
but um my time my luck right like you
never even think about it you ever see
The Godfather - it's like I see the
scene from godmother - right okay yeah
Godfather - off when Michael Patek finds
out but here Mike Alfredo betrays him
okay and there's a little Cuban doing
the back playing little congress's [ __ ]
to make a long story short this could
only happen to me in that Cuban
community in Union City it was a club
called loot like the Oriole Club 38 and
the guy that owned it his claim to fame
was his grandfather had the biggest dick
in Cuba but now he had the biggest thing
like it was a generational thing that
went bad I mean this is this is just
ridiculous
it's just ridiculous it good fairly it's
[ __ ] ridiculous so we can leave the
time I saw this is it I know you don't
know no The Godfather Godfather - I want
capital letters leave you what the
college don't do anything if they do yes
they do capital letters for Christ's
sakes Jesus Christ he's like a
two-year-old
you know these [ __ ] kids they text
they forget everything all right hold on
scraps but Godfather - so what is the
big dick New Jersey guy have to do with
getting me because the big thing in the
big dick in New Jersey oh when my
finds out Fredo Burt Michael and Fredo
in the Cuban crest
alright the thing that has to do and it
was right there that is okay
Vega three minutes and old videos on
another area
what's this see it's a brilliant seen it
it's what I talked about direct things
can you imagine people would leave New
York to do this on the weekend to go
watch this on the weekends this is
brilliant
see all this Vegas [ __ ] started the van
and you [ __ ] 50 they were doing this
I'd speed it up but how far just keep
going to it we see
[Music]
what's with the questions
giggle giggle what's with the quest of
his own you don't you know you go right
there
[Music]
listen to the bongos in the back
tremendous one you all right this poor
little immigrant girl they tie her up
right and then this guy with the big
dick comes out gives it to her and
people pay this is watch this [ __ ]
that's the guy with the big dick he's
got a cape on now Mike he's just hanging
out right watch this
[Music]
then he shows it a dick she [ __ ]
loses her mind look at them no that was
his grandfather
the direct that never shows you this
here you go
Johnny Ola told me about this place in
rock media I didn't believe it maecenas
will even be much back home and Rob had
never come here but old Johnny knows he
places like the back of his hand right
there you rather the stuff I look at my
crack
he gets [ __ ] on just he knows he
betrayal
there's a brilliant scene but the table
to show you the guy's dick you wouldn't
see Michael's face right
that's a brilliant directorial scene so
everybody in the room how will they show
you God now they would do that in 1975
this kid was doing that in Union City
and he would come to my mom's bra and
always like we'd be shooting pool but in
the conversation like even with my
friends it didn't know nothin about
nothin' he just said you know my
grandfather had the biggest dick in Cuba
and my friends would look at me like why
is he telling us this like [ __ ]
he's like shooting pool I wish there was
[ __ ] boy I knew he would Thomas that is
he had that it was a thing in his family
and I told my mom was like don't worry
he's not a bad guy his name was Willie
Vandy
so Willie Vandy had a bar once I found
that he had a big dick and this is what
he did at that bar on Saturday nights
during the week they played salsa but on
Saturdays he would showcase his dick it
was a good comedy show hey you know what
he would showcase it every week like
every Saturday night every neighborhood
knew if you wanted to see his dick you
went down there he find some like him
like somebody take a dog he'd get like
some Nicaraguan runaway I was like in
the 70s nobody gave a [ __ ] about
Nicaragua right like take it think of a
country nobody gave a [ __ ] about in the
70s he would get one of their refugees
they dumped him up and it was legal like
they paid the cops off well not every
Satur doesn't mean it's legal well you
know whatever they were having fun he'd
come out and he'd go they paid him and
he'd give him a stabbing in public with
that there were two with his three-foot
dick
oh and [ __ ] people would pay 20 bucks
and hang out and have drinks with the
guy what if what does this [ __ ] that's
like Woody Allen's friends you know
saying like yeah yeah but couldn't the
guy just learned how to juggle
it was [ __ ] dick I think I mean like
I never liked the dude but the first
time my dad but there was a car valve
down the corner do you know the car
valeted yeah nice can't ice cream joint
that was one of my favorites because you
feeling on ice cream
and I go yeah so when we went to get ice
cream it was down on the bottom that boy
goes let me stop in there cuz Willy has
to give me money
but then another time I went in there
with him I guess my stepfather was like
a half a loan shark and he loaned the
Willy money and we'll he always kept
[ __ ] with him so one night Willie was
supposed to meet him there and Willie
didn't meet him
so my stepfather on a Saturday night had
[ __ ] 11 o'clock and we went in there
and he goes to sit right then he took
the thing out of his jacket and it was
uh you know those homemade zip guns only
with what's is it gun a zip gun is what
you make it and I made gun with a 22 and
it's got one bullet and I gotta get you
with it I know like a nail then a shoe
like a nail it's like a [ __ ] pen no
no in the 70s and 80s I had friends
tonight
I know place in the Bronx where you can
buy them they were like a disposable one
bullet
how long have you been doing this
podcast with Joey you've never so easy
consuming oh my god he had a zip gun
only with that air in it that that tube
that onion smell that it would break out
in people's he put me in the corner and
he went to the back of this place and
left it like BAM that off
I'm nothing I guess think bomb like I
said like uh uh it was distinct mom but
uh whatever that is mace oh my god favor
spray he discharged it in the back of
the club and then we walked out together
like that happened but that's the last
time I got it in my eyes I must have
been 10 or 11 and maybe tops 12 but I
don't think so I was a kid and that was
his way Oh food him with the guy you're
not gonna have my money we only gonna
make no money in the salad either I
gotta have his money the next week yeah
bad nobody got hurt
sounds like it was a full loan shark
doesn't sound like half of nowhere told
you that he was [ __ ] when it came to
all that [ __ ] II was a genius when he
came to all that type of dirty
I got masive there so there's the first
time I ever went to Paris
and I think it's kind of cool that I was
maced in the city of love I was living
with this this French woman in San
Francisco we go to Paris to visit her
mom she got sick and I got to go out by
myself one night so I'm walking around
the the Bastille areas like the
Greenwich Village of Paris so I'm
walking around without Bastille besty
like when they had the French Revolution
it was the Bastille prison that they
tore down and broke open and let all the
prisoners out that was the big symbol of
the revolution so I'm walking on the
Bastille area there's a street called
the Rue de Lappe and that's a street
with all these bars on it and I'm
walking down I can go to any of these
bars and have a drink I come across this
bar called some girls that's the name of
a Rolling Stones album I love the
Rolling Stones I go in they only play
the Rolling Stones
I'm in heaven I'm drinking beer brewed
by monks I'm having a I'm enjoying my my
own company I'm making notes you know
I'm just really having them in Paris and
every time I wanted to leave they play
another great song like can you hear me
knock and give me shelter and I'd order
another beer
finally I leave this bar it's late
there's no one on the street now it's
this thin Parisian Street and these two
guys are walking towards me in the
distance and this guy had a medal
walking yet a metal pole and he's
walking like it's a walking brace but it
wasn't a walking brace it was a metal
pole and then they got close they get
closer I move over to make room for them
then they move it a little more and then
I moved over a little more and then
before I knew it they are right up on
top of me and dude with the pole jams me
in the stomach with it and it's go time
baby it's two against one and I'm not
proud of it I don't know where it came
from I barked at them [ __ ] animal
instinct came out of me like wow I had
no defense whatsoever and then the guy
with the pole starts whaling on me man
but it was winter and I had a big coat
on and it actually didn't hurt too bad
anyone yeah
and that helped for it not hurting too
bad oh my and then I look to see what
dude number two was doing I looked at
dude number two and he maced me right in
the eyes ever never felt such
excruciating pain in my life you have no
idea how many nerve endings in your eyes
and I I broke free and I'm just you know
weld my arms and broke free and I'm
running and I'm blinded in all this pain
and I got away from them I'm sure they
you know looked at each other and
thought did that guy [ __ ] bark in US
but my why they attacking you what do
they want well they don't have guns okay
they they don't have guns
there so I heard later that that's a
very common way for people to get mugged
in Paris or where you know they makes
you they beat you up they get you down
they take your money take whatever so it
took me I was probably staying about a
mile and a half from where I was maced
it took me I think two or three hours to
get home where I was staying because I
would walk a few steps and then it would
it would hit me and the pain was so
crippling I had this I'd sit in like a
doorway and just you know and just sit
there in pain and and whimper and then
thank God it started to rain and then I
could I'd like hold my eyes open and
feel the rain in my eyes and and then
finally eventually I got back and I used
to have really long hair back then you
remember me and my French girlfriend not
to do she tried to help me help baby
what's your eyes baby and like I guess I
had little particles of it in my hair
and like a little some particles got in
her eyes and then she's [ __ ] on the
ground rolling around and pain and [ __ ]
man it went on until like sunrise this
[ __ ] lasted forever [ __ ] on a
parent's [ __ ] that no [ __ ] parents just
have a lot of problems lately right yeah
the battle on and well that's oh but I'm
from Orlando look we had the pulse
nightclub shooting so yeah you're
nobody's [ __ ] rabbit full either
and someone Abell what the [ __ ] do you
wanna do you are from Roland or
that's right um yeah I mean I'm I was
born in DC and then my family moved to
Orlando when I was 12 when I wouldn't
stay out of Paris Lee what do you rather
be in Paris or you've you went to the
patisserie there and had some hay they
have they have bakeries here there are
cheap imitations of what's happening and
I would love to I would love to see
parts of Europe but if they're gonna
maze people I mean I've been back I've
been back twice I've been back 35 times
it's never happened again okay you know
you'll never be basely i love croissants
with a little country because you're
like [ __ ] croissants what else yeah
you said patisserie I'll give you I'll
give you a chew I'll give you a good
travel tip for Paris if you ever go to
Paris some of the the subway there's
called the Metro okay and some of the
Metro cars have a flip latch because you
have to like flip this this the latch to
to open the door I learned that the hard
way the first time I was there like I
got to my stop and the door didn't open
and like a [ __ ] [ __ ] I was like I
just walked over with his finger just
went flip the [ __ ] thing opened so
avoid the jackass moment that I
experienced if you're in Paris and the
doors don't open
remember there's a little flip it's one
finger really go you stay in a hotel
yeah no yeah you have the same boat I
use oh no no no I stayed different parts
of town
oh it's interesting I stayed there in
December I was there in December I did
this small club and this female comedian
who lives there was out of town and let
me stay at her place
and she lives in the saint-germain
neighbourhood of Paris which is the the
Beverly Hills of Paris and I couldn't
figure out her heat and it was [ __ ]
freezing
so I'm sleeping like with my clothes
layered and my winter coat on so it was
funny to stay in like the richest part
of town and then like I'm it was like
sleeping [ __ ]
outside in this place I take like really
hot showers and it's like for an hour
and everywhere you go there's Americans
right uh yes um there's a handful that
not every city went to did all those
shows and China do those tons of
Americans yeah yeah there's expats all
over China right yeah I'm like I'm very
jealous of all that traveling so you're
29 you got a world by the balls and you
want to sit here [ __ ] around and go to
Long Beach nobody how would you like to
go away Japan some Japan's my number one
in Asia I'll be back in Tokyo the end of
June come on early
there's your excuse that's you know just
a great little Club where else would you
go ah I should get leave five minutes
yeah I'll get you five minutes I'm there
all right we could do five lines if I'm
[ __ ] Hong Kong yeah everybody stand
up Tokyo say we come Tokyo well switch
Australia would be really cool I think
that was in Australia in September at
the Comedy Store
see like that's him that's the guy I
haven't done anything in Europe but uh
and then I also like honestly like
something when Joey's talked about I
haven't really been anywhere in America
I've been a few places but like that's
part of the traveling I'd like to see
like I haven't been intending like the
national monuments on the East Coast
went to Israel did you reckon he stops
anywhere I went to Jordan for a day
couple days it was fun Jordan it wasn't
that I went to the where they filmed
Indiana Jones
I like Jordan because they like Michael
Jordan so much they named their country
after him so you do comedy of Israel at
all I have not I'm supposed to go there
in December and do books Gloria yeah how
many books the room right you have to be
clean good to be really clean real clean
right yeah right that sucks that means
I'll never get yeah yeah no there has to
be somewhere in Israel that would put
you up cuz it's oh yeah I heard tel-aviv
you can you know you can you can be more
risque but in Jerusalem they oh yeah I'm
gotta be right clean really yeah they
take Jerusalem seriously especially like
the whole part it's like the more like
every religion that's like the mistake
most sacred part of the
world so they take it pretty seriously
that is that's it that's as good as it
gets right yeah for everybody like
there's the Armenians had the Christian
side there's the Muslims had in the
Jewish side yeah so if you have to be
clean yeah that's a [ __ ] Church time
it's pretty cool you can see like monks
walking around
my friend's wife ex-wife is there she's
been posting pictures on Facebook and
it's pretty interesting what you see
when you go it's gotta be whatever
religion you are or thinking of becoming
it's gotta wake it up a little bit it
has to wake up your religious experience
a little bit going over there even like
I was a I know it was never really a big
religious person not like I wonder what
it was I'm agnostic or wherever I am but
yeah I've been over there twice and it's
pretty it's just it it makes you because
all the stories you heard growing up
it's just it makes you think you know
you try to be respectful it has a lot of
me even if you don't necessarily believe
in God if you just have to just see all
those people coming together to do what
like it's pretty impressive you have
really really just anything in your body
I I used to be more religious my family
are a hardcore Christians and I think
there's a superiority that comes with
real staunch believers in anything
whether we think they're better than
anyone like I live in a Brian the
neighborhood I live in is like Orthodox
Jewish like not the nicest people ever
lay [ __ ] they don't say hi I walk
through the neighborhood and they don't
say hello to you so it's interesting I I
wanted I pitched a you know my comedy
travel show idea and you know they do
stand-up in Israel and then also they do
stand-up in Palestine there's a Ramallah
Comedy Festival and every year I'm not
gonna find there Joey I thought it would
be interesting to show how people on
either side use humor to deal with their
circumstances and you know the the
troubles that they're dealing with and
like Comedy Central when I pitched it to
them
I mean I it was a whole Travel Show
about comedy and humor around the world
and and they said that they they didn't
think that the idea was provocative and
subversive enough [ __ ] it's more
provocative and subversive than stand-up
comedy in Israel and Palestine you know
like what they making jokes about so but
you know if I was if I was 30 years
younger right
I always thought that'd be a great idea
to have a Travel Show where a comedian
would do stand-up in a different country
every week and talk about his experience
on stage what he thought was different
you know it's saying the old days when
you went to Austin you could talk about
George Bush on stage when you went to
Houston mention Bush that was the
envious set you follow me there's got to
be certain countries that you have to
touch on one thing and they might just
[ __ ] stop breathing you don't like
that I've been you know I was in
Charlotte this last weekend and I went
off a couple of nights I was eaten
animals and [ __ ] so I went off early
why'd you go up on just went off you
like on States like you just go off on a
[ __ ] tangent about [ __ ] then
whatever and I was kind of risque and I
remember that I did this creative
entertainment 30 years ago cream oh yeah
I started out on her cell how the
circuits were there he was still out
with them for me creative entertainment
the two weeks I did were dealing
lightbulbs was if I did ten shows I
bombed 11 though I'm not gonna lie the
and then they put me into heaven when
I'm in Jacksonville I will never forget
this 98 97 Jimmy Schubert got him go he
got the movie go and he had a canceled
quick so I thought I got a plane ticket
for 100 bucks to Jacksonville and I
hated a bag of dicks
from Tuesday's straight to Sunday
including Friday night after all the or
you could eat buffet you know I I just
died Tom Tom first off I wasn't the
headlining that was number one I had the
time but that doesn't mean I was a
headline
and when I got to those one-nighters I
couldn't flip it the only one I did
decent that was clark ville or there's
an army base was an army barracks and
the only reason why they even liked me
even better because before the show Mike
they couldn't start the show because the
World Series was huh but I was running a
commercial at the time for Taco Bell the
first one with the dog it was the first
series with the dog and they were
popular and I was in this commercial so
that's the only reason why they laughed
at me but that whole run West Virginia
there was a college I did on that run
that when you did call me on a ping-pong
table and if you said the word [ __ ] they
find you $50 I think I'd break the
ping-pong table you know that was in yes
morning Morganville something [ __ ]
I'm not saying them by member all those
rooms ie dollars you said the word [ __ ]
$50 fine and I didn't find out till you
get there
I was like this is not gonna work how
much we getting for the set 250 I was
headlining so what if he said six fox
did their lumber the - I ain't a bag of
dog I ate a bag of dog dicks at
University of North Carolina like my
[ __ ] that was the school I wanted to go
to when I was a basketball player I was
finally in Charlotte whatever Chapel
Hill I finally get the Chapel Hill and
before the headliner goes up there's a
[ __ ] drinking contest through you
know it was one of those tours like I
just got to kiss a [ __ ] that thought
mean Knoxville was the best night
because some crazy girl was there and it
was just crazy it was just a crazy night
but that that was it you know what on
the way home you end the weekend like I
did it was two weeks on the creative run
tour and the first week was almost
one-niners but the second week and I
ended up in a club in West Virginia they
have and they actually had a real Club
on Fridays and Saturdays but the problem
was for me to get a ride back to
Charlotte I had to leave at 4:00 in the
morning to get a free ride so basically
I went back to Charlotte to sit in the
[ __ ] Denny
all day cuz my flight was a 10 o'clock
at night but I had gotten a guest spot
at that same club where I'd performed
last week so this is not another 10
bombing it's in two weeks and I'm going
to do a guest set into the Charlotte
comedy zone and not only do I hate the
biggest bag of dicks of the week that
was it like that was the longest flight
I ever took in my life and I swore on
that continental flight because I never
forgot what the airline was but I would
never go back to the Bible Belt again
like I bombed everywhere Nashville I
just wanna [ __ ] like a Vietnam tour
like I just got bombed that's all they
did I started out doing though she oh my
god and then I grew my hair long and I
was called [ __ ] nine million times
please in those rooms oh well I had been
doing copy Tom was I prepared I guess
there's some rough rooms man I remember
that like that and then the Booker you
know yeah we're gonna book you for these
one-nighters in the Carolinas but you
got a swing by Memphis and pick up the
headliner yeah what the [ __ ] it's
nowhere near the Carolinas like that
like at Tom I've been doing open mics
for like two and a half months that
probably even just the alley I was
looking at I'm like I'm after spending
like a hundreds of dollars I think
probably at least a hundred bucks and
then like with gas and just waiting
because you sit there for 15 minutes to
do five it's like a lot it's like
mentally you have to like be hot it's
kind of it kind of like taxing a little
bit like you know man [ __ ] it's harder
than it seems
[ __ ] ain't for the weak like a hundred
dollars like and I drove to Brea back
and forth one night I was like Jesus
Christ that's but it's finite that's
what you do every day
that's that's though that's what you
don't understand when you do it for free
you know I'm saying like you'll never do
anything for free time you visited my
you wanna wash my car Joey yeah give me
the small 25 please let me get a little
six-pack you know
I'm gonna get the bodies done yeah what
did you do it for free for time I made
thanks a long time yeah yeah it kills me
when people still take three cents every
now and then yeah people still say I
love when people I am and don't call me
for three years or no
somebody asked me to do a free room I
don't believe him okay so my skills
young guys the last guy hey when can I
expect to start getting paid for this
oh my god yeah you gotta think here
you're in the wrong business if you
trade on their first open mic night
their second open mic night and they
want to know when they can start making
money I [ __ ] know oh yeah I like that
I want a contest and they made me the
house MC so I got $50 a week since 200 a
month so for two years I made twenty
four hundred years that's fourteen
hundred big bazoo this guy I'm saying
tax rate 15 all the tater tots you
cannae oh my god oh my friend shrimp
shrimp in those days on Tuesday nights
but it's just crazy that you uh this
comedy has taken you all over now let me
ask you a question before the MBC show
we were you traveling abroad no I was
the when the sitcom ended I looked at
that money as my NBC artist grant so
I've started taking trips to London and
and now I took in a few trips of London
and and that's how I got in once I got
in with London then I started work in
London and then London was the key to
the International circuits for me
because like everything was booked out
of London back then all these
international this Hong Kong China tour
Australia all these cool gigs you know
but before that you know I told you I
lived in New York City when I was 20
like a dog in Washington Heights I
couldn't afford anything else and I
always swore if I ever had any money I'd
live in New York City of style so after
my sitcom ended I moved to New York and
I got a place in the Wall Street area
and total rock star pad lived there for
two years and then
while I was living there and play in New
York and you know I was really partying
harder than I ever had and then I
started taking these trips to London and
you know did the peripheral rooms first
because you don't go to the best club
first you know you want to get your sea
legs as a performer especially going to
a different country but this advice
applies for New York San Francisco la
Chicago you know you go to you go to
some perfume rooms first you know see if
your shit's gonna work in that city you
don't go to the best club and [ __ ]
have a wobbly set and then they remember
you is some wobbly [ __ ] act you know
you wait until the pistols are on it's
sold the little rules in cowboy is so
subtle but that could change a life like
I wish it was podcast to listen to when
we were starting yeah yeah like you know
he's [ __ ] young guys he listened to
you know they just got that pearl of
wisdom but it's funny how they usually
way you start you get no respect like
for years I wouldn't get booked and done
yep and then ticket started selling saw
son now been dead book and I get it I
understand the business level of it but
throughout my career now one club from
Denver ever contacted me and say hey man
I saw you in a film you know right
people don't realize that that's the
most painful thing that that's your home
[ __ ] Club well I always say like for
years I you know I didn't get any
respect in Orlando and I would always
say they thought Jesus was a punk in
Nazareth you know he had to take his
show on the road before he got any
respect you know downhole and go
[ __ ] yeah and oh yeah I've been
playing or land if I can pray like 10
years gets it for years I couldn't get
them to [ __ ] work me and it's like my
hometown ok for years there's a club
that I used to go by on a bus before I
ever dreamed of doing comedy when I was
robbing gas stations yeah I would look
at that comedy club it's just a comedy
club going what goes on
do don't say like I would look up and go
what the [ __ ] goes on to that like I
never even dawned on me about stand-up
comedy but I became a comic I bugged
them for years
can I get in I'm originally from North
Bergen no no no no no then finally some
people friend of mine worked there and I
asked him to bring me and he brought me
and I got like more [ __ ] people came
to see me then went to see him this is
2000 [ __ ] to 2003 maybe 2004 you know
it never offered out an extra hem below
they stuck to the original pay for shows
for 200 bucks you know even though I
brought a bunch of people in there my
friends ate there so for years I'm koala
Bleen oh hey man
let me have a lion Thanksgiving no no no
they treated me like [ __ ] [ __ ] what
three years ago they started calling me
and offering me like [ __ ] the door
like how about if we just give them the
door that would say no like for some
reason you're supposed to forgive what's
what's that word forgiven forgot I have
grudges yeah
but till this day I have a grudge
against them because they never gave me
any [ __ ] love when I really need it
so you don't play that club no yeah I
didn't ask him for much it wasn't like I
was even asking for money
yeah how about I dunno Wednesday like
just for me to get together with my high
school friends and have a good time and
they could sell drinks yeah you know
it's so [ __ ] way and how where you
start you that's why you leave it's
because you don't get no respect to be
so if you started Chicago they don't
like it you would to Detroit I'd next
thing you know you're though I am people
registered I started in Chicago but they
hate my [ __ ] guts I think the same
thing happens with people in offices
like for like I love my first job here
in LA but at a certain point they're
gonna say if you started as an intern
they see you as the intern for at least
for some people some people can break
through that but it is hard I think no
it's all differently Tommy and whatever
Tommy was that it yeah yeah no no no
no no wasn't kind of you was a club
called bananas which is next door to the
bada-bing
where they shot The Sopranos you don't
have the Sopranos in Denver they shot
the Jersey oh okay I want four room four
okay and this club was called bananas
now they sold it's under new ownership
okay and I'm considering playing there
but I'm not sure yet huh they just
wanted the owner didn't want to work
with those owners anymore that wasn't a
club in Jersey where the it was like the
owner guy had like a garage sale set up
in the front yard and the front foyer a
of the club with these glass cases do
you remember that I don't know you right
now you have the stress factory
yeah Bram which is a good club then you
haven't been there in a long time like a
little I used to work there a lot I love
Vinny loved that room that's a good
little killer run across room you know
and there was but the rhythm then there
was Rascals
there was rascals Nort and Rascals out
Rascals Lord was a [ __ ] rail yeah I
think it was Rascals South that had the
garage sale in the lobby Rascals South
was route 35 next to a Russian strip
club that pay you walked in there you
gotta have a [ __ ] winter jacket on
Russian chicks like me cold
I wonder there one time after a comedy
show me why is it [ __ ] freezin this
[ __ ] place and then bananas is inside
a hotel and there's like a restaurant
next to it like a hotel restaurant and
bananas is like you go in there they
have my old furniture it's one of those
clouds would have like picnic tables
what do you mean they have lawn
furniture is the East Coast so nobody
gives a [ __ ] like that type of club they
have those type of clubs of Boston also
whether a bank at all they were banquet
hall but you turn them into a one-night
I've been to one one of the Chinese
restaurants yeah and also yeah they're
awesome there are some of that's bananas
it's small the ceiling small there's no
stage it's like a stepping thing whether
they you step one you never did bananas
and all your [ __ ] nose is that you
know it it's right under the George
Washington Bridge right underneath the
George Washington
the last off route 4 like you'd see has
been going for the bridge you could see
it right there and then just happen to
be next to the bada bing the bada bing I
don't know if that's the real name of it
and real they closed it recently it was
next to the strip club where they shot
the superlatives so for years recently
they were if you're a tourist you go
Times Square and take a bus over to the
bottom Bing and to the museum there but
the two idiots got in trouble for tax
evasion and then paid taxes on the
[ __ ] money and they just recently
closed it down article hut the down
bada-bing closes see if I'm good you see
a pattern here listeners if you're a
criminal
pay the taxes so it's where they pay
your [ __ ] back where they get you
look up and they get you on those
autograph shows or [ __ ] that's how yeah
wait give the ten years all these
comic-con right Bob they're all gonna be
doing 20 years a bunch of these [ __ ]
comic-con nickel heads on man cuz they
go down there they sign 25-hour
autographs way a new cheat and what do
you think of Tom Rhodes got fifty out
autographs and we got fifty autographs
wise there's only get five voting
drivers you go to jail [ __ ] and don't
let you do it for like five or ten years
they'll give you a leeway yeah no
problem
they'll come to [ __ ] comic-con take
pictures of you with twenty people and
then one day you get the weather in the
mail excuse us our [ __ ] the records
indicate that you really had nineteen
you're lying that that you go to court
in awesome they play this video when you
giving out autographs and jumping up and
down is the character you were 80 years
ago [ __ ] they're sending that kid from
[ __ ] Jersey Shore to jail you bet
your ass test under that [ __ ] go
to jail well from the TV show
yeah whatever teen [ __ ] years the one
the no way
yes they are how much City glass how
much did he make its fed time he'll do
six and a [ __ ] country club why
didn't his autograph money yeah let's
find it fine what's his name yeah their
bada-bing closed on the 17th okay the
bada-bing causing the seventeenth don't
look up what the situation he's
here's 6dv they're looking at 15 that
means if it's federal time you do seven
good behavior five and a half they send
you up to Lompoc you play tennis you
learn how to milk cows it's not that bad
so I'm gonna [ __ ] let it take me to
jail and [ __ ] them spray mace in your
eyes okay yeah when you know listen let
me tell you so but you don't pay your
taxes they throw you in jail ain't that
bad hold on you've just said on this
podcast like you didn't pay taxes for
like a decade you went in there and
they're sitting up on a plan why can't
he go on a plan because listen the plan
is you've when you [ __ ] up and you
forget to send your taxes in and you
made $9,000 when there is a comedy they
don't give a [ __ ] about that okay it's
when you make how much did he make
alright uh oh he defrauded them by
almost nine million a plan you're gonna
do some [ __ ] time but in three years
2000 2010 to 2012 that's three million
he was selling a lot of autographs what
would they be got a month and then he
tried to draw us nine million I don't
know if it was the autographs I might be
wrong on it fraudulent business
deductions income five years on each
count [ __ ] they don't [ __ ] around he
faces a maximum sentence of 10 years Wow
so he's got a great attorney so all the
money I put away and all the money stole
you've gotta use the better accountants
while he go to the toilet Ernie
hey bro they got forensic accountant the
feds they go through your ass they found
they find one discrepancy that's why all
these people for years would write off
everything in comedy and then comics
started getting [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] because they were doing those
business dinners and all that [ __ ]
everything was a [ __ ] write-off now
we'll ain't know what ain't good luck
you gotta do something a little bit
different they have people there
forensic accountants
what they do for a [ __ ] living I
cannot believe something like way the
landscape what's going on what's going
on Tom road you every Paris man no I
don't smoke another [ __ ] any no
right comes in you're acting like ya
don't like somebody don't you
Alysha holding out on me holding you got
some xanax no man huh having done a long
time ago so you're sober now I'm sober
yeah completely I I smoke a little weed
once in a while but I have told you
before my wife was from Holland hates it
okay and I've had just [ __ ] people
send me emails you know you were fake it
man do some edibles and don't tell her
like yeah once I start telling a long
story with a lot of pauses she knows
it's you know the goose is cooked
now she just you know she only I only
smoke minimal amount of times a month
and treat it like a treat that type of
thing has it changed you as a calm
because yeah you're more focused I get
more [ __ ] done this you know cuz I used
to I used to smoke like every day you
were professional well what's a pretty
you know I hate when people use the way
I hate when people give people
stereotypes you're a comic bro when you
send it to be the comic if you don't
like I love Jim Gaffigan I love I love
every [ __ ] comic you know whatever
everybody has their lifestyle mm-hmm but
when I sign them to be a comic it was to
do this so he ended up like [ __ ] Lenny
Bruce yeah you know that was the book
I'm not gonna lie yeah me too man all my
heroes died fat naked and bloated on the
bathroom child so you know when you dive
into this you hope that you get good you
figure out how to do it she would figure
out the lifestyle we want to live which
is a no responsibility lifestyle it's or
I don't really have an address I got a
Pio bug somewhere mission
and that's all you the I didn't that I
didn't have an address for ten years you
know the weirdest thing that you commit
to that life for somebody likely it's
imaginable but with calmly you could
just drop out of society right now way
like if you didn't want anybody to find
you all you have to do is just do
Tribble runs under like a different name
though you could usually saya
you're still gonna pay taxes do
everything but nobody would know where
you were you would dis communicate with
everyone with cloud Li you could do that
with Romney that's the reason I did it
deferred when I [ __ ] left Boulder the
main purpose was to dis communicate my
life had been everybody went to prison I
got divorced I hate I steal I lied I got
thrown on a [ __ ] in the university I
got my GED I quit high school when I
dove in to come in 1995 that was it all
that was was a pager and a p.o box
checked you were not gonna get a hold of
me I did not want a cellphone you I did
not want responsibility I wanted to be
Charles Bronson in a single apartment
with some books a little cot and the
black-and-white TV and I was good to go
yeah that's why you get it I didn't
expect them to come you know all tab
money in the beginning four years I knew
I was going to suffer I do think I mean
I don't really want to do that and see
that's honestly that was part of my
thinking whenever when anyone would ask
me if I why I didn't do comedy like I
don't really want like to do ten years
of like that like that doesn't really
sound appealing when you guys tell those
stories but when you like you got to do
it you're never gonna get to the you're
never gonna get to samurai's status
without how long will you broke four
before everything started clicking for
you
10-12 years receptive being broke I
sleep on friends couches
you may stay hitchhike two gigs I take
Greyhound buses in the south to do those
butt-fuck gigs you talked about earlier
there's comedy zones oh [ __ ] it's the
[ __ ] hit no I was like I started on a
17 I'm gonna hit one on the road at 18
so like 18 19 I'm in the backwater
southern circuits and then when I was 20
I moved to New York City you know but 18
19 I was doing all this but [ __ ] gigs
all over the south everywhere
I don't mind driving I don't I'll Drive
everywhere but I need at least like a
motel 6 or looking I can't I don't like
sleeping on people's your family have
money that's gonna pay for this hotels
and gas and stuff now see that the other
thing it's hard it's uh if you're
starting in California - it's a whole
different world you know is a problem
way you can sleep out on the grass
anywhere probably nobody's ever shut the
lights off our way and what does that
mean you to really build yourself up you
really got a scrub some type of the
bottom to really see the top you know
there's no Motel 6
you know take this job away from you and
go on the road and live on a hundred
hours a night you love this so in your
heart you will make it work that
Volkswagen becomes a paper for previous
Prius the back has a blanket see how I
wanna do that Leslie Vallejo look cooler
and you learn to adapt I can sandwich
power I would take a mine RV and just do
that that's great you could buy an RV
listen to me the biggest gift I got from
calmly was the gift of survival
learning how to survive we learned how
to Sandlot or another pee into a cup
bottle while driving yes time to stop
dude you got to get to this gear you
learn
and you accept well you know you'll take
a gig for 75 bucks to break even just to
get the hotel room that night to cover
you - you get the SantaFe I'm fine the
first gig I ever took out of Florida was
in Tulsa Oklahoma I tried the week to MC
for 150 dollars I drew from or I drove
from Orlando to Tulsa halfway across the
country for my probably cost more than
gas you know I'm sleeping at rest areas
you know I mean but I was like like
1918-19 it was like if and I just felt
like I'll never forget pulling into the
Tulsa City Limits I mean like I was like
excited about it I felt I could have
been doing like - tonight's show or the
SNL or something I remember feeling like
man I'm in show business
yeah yeah [ __ ] I'm gonna play in Tulsa
[ __ ] my first date my first trip [ __ ]
wasn't it Ogden Utah well a girl her
boyfriend just tweeted me the end day
from hog man and all I heard that name I
went back into at that time for like two
minutes how excited I was that I was
performing in Ogden Utah Lee in my world
it was bigger than Las Vegas at that
time my shirt was ironed my shoes were
shine didn't matter I bombed but what
she looked great when I look good
I look you know like that lead that's
it's a different mindset you're just so
happy to be that somebody's paying you
for what you've done for the last four
years for free that that's the last on
your head
I'm asking them to get me the hotel
listen to me
you probably got 380 holes in your
account when you get this tool again
which is gonna cost you 150 to get there
and gas and back you're not gonna have
no money for a homecoming and I talked
to you it's not done by email you have
no negotiation they pay you to allows
and sleep in your car and your heart
breaks down and yeah
listen Dean del rey's 50 and I've seen
him do things that I lied Dean down
because Dean dowry will do a comedy show
and wait till 10 o'clock and tap into
that website that gives you tour around
a hotel room for 30 oh yeah and that
[ __ ] will sit there no five
minutes after 12 the next day he'll get
room service or live like a doctor he
that there's a way if you really love
something right it happens you know yeah
well I had no time fax I thought no you
go three days without a motel and you'll
love what you're doing you'll love you
know Subway sandwiches you'll love
pulling over rolling those joints and
peeing outside the window and peeling
the snow
it just becomes however being a tween
but you wouldn't think it out don't
won't listen whoo jazz I'd rather have
weed in the hotel room and have a story
to tell any day of the week me and Jody
fur they got driving on the 5 Alan
Trimble one and we've got a two-door car
that the backseat the trunk fits nothing
there's a two-door car was a saturn
two-door coupe and the back was up to
the top with woman's clothes like I had
a suitcase but Joanie fertig had enough
clothes to go away for 10 years and on
the top of that was a white shirt with a
[ __ ] beautiful her favorite white
shirt to wear she would wear it on
Friday nights because it showcased her
tits she's passed out up in the [ __ ]
car she's like Joey we should stop and
get a hotel in those days we never have
my she wasn't getting 85 bucks and I was
getting 175 I was a date huh I wasn't
pay for the hotel room here she was
freezing how is [ __ ] freezing and
I'll never forget I was smoking a singer
with the window open I would throw the
cigarette out the window and I was I'm
sitting I'm like man this car smells
[ __ ] up and I went back and I see
Jodi's white shirt with a 6-inch hole in
it oh yeah I had to [ __ ] take the
shirt while she was sleeping and throw
it out the window and something elseö
then I took like a jacket of mine and
put it down like nothing ever happened
for three years she kept asking me I
never know what happened to that white
shirt I should call the hotel and [ __ ]
now I little unfiled
like those of the adventures Lee oh my
adventures going on in that car I love
driving it that's not that part sounds
like fun just doing open mics across the
country you don't know you imagine a
world that doesn't exist Lee I don't
know where everything's fine and it's a
struggle yeah he's delusional since I
moved out here I don't know to tie this
into you know you asked me about being
sober and everything another thing about
how I'm conducting my life right now is
I'm trying to get some [ __ ] done you
know I've been working on this book for
like six seven years now I wrote the
first draft finished that like about a
year ago so I'm trying to get this book
ready for publication so like it's got
he's insane Road stories from when I
first went on the road my life you know
when I had the sitcom when I had the
late-night talk to Amsterdam getting
maced in Paris the almost drowning in
Thailand all these like insane stories
that have happened to me as a comedian I
mean my you know epic life basically and
you know my dad was killed by a drunk
driver my sister died of breast cancer I
got married at her hospital bedside
hours before she died of cancer you know
I've had a pretty [ __ ] epic story so
I you know a lot of these feel a lot of
comedians put out these books and
they're these little cream puffs [ __ ]
105 page books and it's their axe that's
transcribed and it's like double spaced
the sentences looks like a third-grade
book with like big thick letters to like
so it can fill a hundred pages you know
I mean mine's like a work I mean mine's
gonna be I don't know how many pages I'm
trying to yeah to chop it down but I
mean it's it's a legitimate
book I mean it's you know
I hate these doored literature but it's
not a cream puff comedians fluff book of
his [ __ ] jokes written you know huh
so the fact that I'm not smoking pot
every day I've been able to whip this
into shape fairly fairly well because
you were a wild guy I want to know how
it affected you stand up at night dude
to go sober yes
it was great I think the beginning when
you make the adjustment it takes it
takes a minute I think you know my
father always been a heavy drinker and
my philosophy was always you know give
me more drugs and my dad who I was very
close with my dad's a reason I'm a
comedian he's killed by a drunk driver
and III was I was I was pretty I was
pretty sad over that and then my sister
died of breast cancer a year and a half
later so I kind of went into the I saw
no joy in life and I really started
drinking heavily
more than I ever did and I started to
look like [ __ ]
and I I started to get this white puffy
you know I white guys have that puffy
alcoholic face with the big bulbous nose
and I look like [ __ ] and I was sluggish
and I blacked out in Philadelphia and
busted my head open and just decided to
stop you told us that the last time you
were here I just wanted to know because
I know a lot of young comics out there
you know when the thought came to my
mind that Hannah stop snorting coke I
was like my career's done like I'll
never be funny again like that's the
first daughter all right
like the I thought the fish we're this
poor bastard get the napkin please
get the map you get the get the begging
Authority
Jesus Christ what I got a little bit of
vomit here let me get you a bucket or
somehow Oh
what's a matter what are you gonna puke
for what did you eat the beautiful what
is the [ __ ] problem I saw you over
there drinking water trickling the
[ __ ] bottle then you switch bottles
what happened are you thinking about
Motel 6's I'm thinking about what's
worse than Motel sex is not that there's
nothing more yes there are I've seen a
lot of month wears well well you go
although they're being Beasley you got
the rash okay yeah air B&B Long Beach
that's terribly the [ __ ] kiss of
death on your life you'll never need a
[ __ ] travel agent
this guy picks the worst low cow's
adverb and then he goes into Jacuzzi
gets up he gets one of those rashes
missus everything was yeah another a B&B
any air B&B you go to you get VD VD
wasn't even around anymore and he
[ __ ] got it got it
someone has together it's uh it's a
scary thought for a lot of people what
to go silver to absolutely absolutely I
think if I I've found it's made me a
better comedian because I'm more focused
on stage I got the I mean I was always
you know the the thing I always said
about comedy the best thing about comedy
is it's the only job you can show up
half in the bag and everybody's still
happy to see it you know but I mean I
was the party guy forever and I enjoyed
it
I don't regret and it was good with your
company you and I are very [ __ ] you
stunned when we met oh my god and you
can't Houston as some of them purest
cocaine available yeah and you would go
to these tunes and you would start on
Tuesday and it was every night so [ __ ]
Sunday morning at Sunday morning you
were at the [ __ ] Airport he knows
breakfast tacos then yourself thank God
the [ __ ] week is over yeah I flew
back from Paris I changed planes in
Atlanta and Atlanta was always a fun
town for me and I just remembered like
that Airport I've been in that Airport
like on like over I would party all
night after the last you know I have so
many great friends in Atlanta and the
staff that worked at the club and
remember just going to that Airport
after partying all night and I have
flown on every possible substance and I
and I I think the best way to fly is
definitely sober look way better than
you know still on mushrooms still high
still drunk still whatever I like
smoking the joint
leaving the park cooking getting on a
plane I'm not gonna win nobody getting
on a plane who low for the night before
to me that is just death death I
remember drinking till 5:00 and the car
picking you up at 7:00
yeah and you showing up in your eyes are
just beaming of alcoholism and drug use
and they look at you in the counter they
look at your God Jesus Christ and yet
and you just read you could brush your
teeth 18 times and you can [ __ ] do 19
Listerine 's and take a shower I was
coming out of your pores was pure
[ __ ] I would smell it I smelled it at
the airport this Sunday was a UFC so a
lot of the guys were going home then oh
and I smoked that smell on the plane
boat it coming out of your body and then
coming out of your breath it's I can't
do it I couldn't deal with that 20 years
ago that was horrible getting high and
having the [ __ ] fly that's a horrible
[ __ ] feeling that I don't know how
people do I applaud you you're the king
of it I die for a long time I applaud
you I would just partying all night get
on a plane
[ __ ] you go straight to the airport oh
yeah anyway so now you know I mean I
think I've reached some kind of level of
maturity and you're an adult you've been
doing this for 30 years you've done it
all next week
February 4th will be 34 years 30 20 in
heard every story of death lived every
story I've been you've gone to every
you know you travel internationally just
[ __ ] amazingly
yeah it's great and you know what I
think what I found is you like the who's
the guy they from Santa Monica mighty
bold you like the whitey ball Tommy you
know he knows like my wife has
conditioned me to like if I if I smoke
pot to make it a special occasion and
it's you know like if I'm hanging out
with Joey Diaz it's a special occasion
it's gotta be somebody who's a good
friend of mine you know what I'm saying
I can't
she doesn't want me you know getting
high with a bikers [ __ ] random people
and like I said I think my my life is
more focused now I'm really sharp on
stage while I'm telling a joke or a
story my rolodex is in my brain all
right I got this and [ __ ] this we can
take them this way we can it's uh it's
but I'm very happy with the way things
are right now for me you know come also
cuz I want to ask you because I know I
feel the difference I hired for me it
was ten years the block you know reefer
I could I could do I could do the
national anthem on reefer I love it
that's doesn't affect me on stage or if
I don't do it a lot of times I don't do
it and I think it's I think I have to
watch energy what I don't get high
sometimes we all right buddy what's
going on with you talk the Uncle Joe he
got me concerned mom but you're like the
first time you're the first time I did
your podcast I think that me that's was
very sorry not tell the story about you
dead yes sister I look at and I looked
at him because he was [ __ ] making
faces that was telling me honey yeah the
[ __ ] was going on look you're right
maybe yeah like a hacker semana you get
the headache
what's the matter dog eat the other
[ __ ] tumor maybe five edibles wasn't a
good night
no we
thanks.thanks why we had two of the
cookies in the four of those wherever
those [ __ ] sticky that's a piece of
it yeah don't worry about nothing nada
they're fun he's all right this pork you
know I've never tried some edibles a
couple years ago and it felt like weight
felt like waiting for an illness to pass
there was nothing enjoyable though he's
eating a little pillow here before tea
chilly she'll rub your shoulders you got
acupuncture she'll pull a deal with this
temple or I'm having a stroke that could
be happening I hope that way whoever
Christ Jesus Christ knock on wood that
bug it took it to the next level this
[ __ ] what do the other one San Francisco
punchline February 7th to the 10th I'll
be at side splitters in Tampa
February 22nd through the 25th then
what's your international schedule like
yeah well I'm again I'm gonna do end of
March I'm doing this this Magners Comedy
Tour
it's I'm doing Bangkok and then it's
some on my website and then I'm gonna do
Hanoi Ho Chi Minh City and then I'm
gonna do Manila and Borak a Philippines
and then I'm going to Hong Kong and then
that's that's the beginning of April and
a March beginning April end of June I'm
gonna go back to Tokyo I'm doing Tokyo
and Osaka and then in August I think I'm
gonna do Shanghai and I'm gonna go back
to Mongolia I did Mongolia last months
ago is there you laughing at link is he
so [ __ ] up
Hey he's robbers he's playing with his
own head is playing with him and he was
sitting there thinking he was getting
this truck I saw his face he's like
maybe I'm having this well I like if you
were having a stroke you'd still finish
the show I think that's
did my little strokes I got like 300 all
right what happens is you puke a little
bit it's why is follow me you're taking
that you get up your be a little dizzy
nothing like my insurance covers the
mileage but you know I've had a couple
more strokes at the house nobody he's
just laying bed watch load on it you get
the girlfriend to make some chicken
noodle soup and you'll be fine tomorrow
you have to do another podcast as we I
think in this what's that this is why I
say to you always in training training
coming you have not done another poll
since we came back from Austin I've been
giving you a breather I figured you go
this once a terrible get yourself some
cheaper choose on your own be it you're
not even country it's just no more
you've lost it I can't do animal like
this it's not like this every night but
it's training you got to do this three
four nights a week later that's why when
you go do comedy at night you stop at
the weed store first then you pop the
edibles and then you do comedy so when
you get off the stage bing-bang-boom
I have a bush out there not up there
when you get offstage I don't that'll
help you kick the the adrenaline will
help you kick but that's completely
different lesson I'm trying to have a
conversation mr. Rhoades here about
international so do me a favor stop
making funny faces you're not gonna die
if you do don't worry about I got a
place where to drop you off
thank you nobody's ever gonna he left
last night what he talking about he was
here he did the pod cave and see him he
didn't leave a note not that nobody saw
hope about a 117 is a little spotted
then we could drop off people nobody
knows nothing there's a hall if you want
to be that girl in that and the big dick
show don't you oh absolutely
from godfather to its what career
opportunities its
you know I know I've always admired you
I really have because I learned
something from BIA that you know I got
into comedy
although I didn't get into comedy to be
on TV I didn't get into comedy do movies
I got into comedy disappear I got into
comedy the place [ __ ] states and place
[ __ ] holes just to survive if I could
just survive and pull a little bit of
money away and live that life of Riley
that we all admire that guy that you
know are here assume we're major-league
yeah
what's what's the catcher who plays the
catcher that I'm over it
don't be mad as [ __ ] Tom Berenger well
yeah barrages characters great he gets a
phone call he's got two naked women on
the bed and he wakes up drunk and he's
playing the Mexican baseball league and
he lives in the whorehouse and he'll and
that's your life and you wait for the
major leagues to call you but until then
you survive and someday you get old and
you die you accept that I'm saying like
that's what I accepted comedy to be I
was gonna be Tom Berenger in the [ __ ]
whatever how it just wouldn't be a
minor-league
comedian I was never gonna take any
success if I ever did come on you'd be
to be an extra but my whole passion with
comedy was that I didn't have to have a
day job I didn't nobody needed to know
who I was like that's it I would call a
book that he would book me and that was
it nobody knew nothing I loved the idea
when I read that book you know he he did
strip clubs Lennie car Lenny Bruce so he
would do strip clubs go back to the
Chelsea shoot heroin and sleep til
[ __ ] 4:00 in the afternoon wake up so
we got a bagel and lox was better than
that who's better than that no
responsibilities no phones no nothing
you don't want people quality that's
what I thought
as obviously became something else and
my life turned into something else you
know but that first couple years
especially when you realize you need to
live on the road to become a good comic
to get a good comic foundation you just
become a note matter like I was an old
man and I know you were all you're the
king of the nomads but I that's not what
I learned from you I learned that when
you get into comedy you look at the
spectrum you know you know what the
highlight of my career will begin the TV
show and for you that wasn't the
highlight of your career you became a
great topic the TV show was more than
just one of many things that you didn't
it didn't define you do you know I'm
saying yeah yeah yeah you know there's
some comedians and with my comics they
got a TV show and they just forget about
being in the comics I respected all that
level but I also respect the way you did
because I remember seeing you at The
Improv maybe four months after the show
was canceled you didn't have a nice look
on your face yeah I was at the Melrose
improv I could be wrong the timing what
the look on your face was and I didn't
know you personally I still like to show
and I liked what you didn't when all the
comedy I used to watch I was a young
comic watching it and I always thought
that after a comic show and get canceled
they would just wrap it up and go sell
real estate you didn't do that oh yeah
you know like after who who could
tolerate that like my show got canceled
you Margaret Cho you guys didn't give a
[ __ ] it made you a better [ __ ]
comedy yeah well I mean you know it
wasn't it wasn't that easy I mean it was
kind of chilling yes I understand why
you know like show business goes
ice-cold on you and people you thought
were your friends stopped taking a call
it's crazy and I stuck around La for for
like a year after the sitcom was
finished and you know people who I
thought were my friends and you know
even my manager stopped taking my calls
and it's pretty [ __ ] chilling and
then that's why I was like
you know [ __ ] this town and I moved to
New York to get deep back into stand-up
comedy and then also like I said I
started using that money to take trips
to London because London is a massive
stand-up comedy town you know and and
brilliant comedy comes out of there and
you know there's people in New York and
London and all they care about is
stand-up and they don't give a [ __ ]
about about TV so and and all I cared
about was stand-up I didn't that that
that TV show was just it was just a blip
you still with us Lee so far it's so
weird what I learned the last oh my god
you know it wasn't just doing comedy
it was also learning about life I saw a
dear friend of mine that got a big deal
twice and I saw how his manager would be
everywhere if you saw him you saw his
manager right once the deal fell through
I never saw the manager I didn't even
know yeah I knew the deal fell through
because I went somewhere and he wasn't
with the manager anymore yeah I was like
this is deal fell through and even
though I would ask him oh yeah it still
a lot you know but that has to be like
the woman you know I was writing about
it this last week like when I got out of
[ __ ] county jail the first time for
kidnapping and my bail and my name was
in the paper in my mind I thought that
you knew I gave it if I didn't know and
I was shopping right and you look at me
I go you have like this feeling that
people looking at you was an experience
to go through that it was a two-week
period where I thought when I went to a
restaurant the whole eggs she was
looking at me because I just got out of
County jail for kidnapping and I think
that would be the same if I had a show
and it got canceled why do you think
people look at how that's hammer is no
shells I don't even know the [ __ ] you
want I don't even watch TV you know but
then the people who were close to you
that's the weirdest thing ever when
people just stop returning your calls it
still
his [ __ ] feeling yeah you know when I
was the Longest Yard Adam Sandler has
his right-hand man you know many times I
call him in the daytime to get
directions or something in stuff well I
mean that day I was off the set he never
picked up the phone again
well it's crazy yeah well you know
that's 20 years later yeah that's what
having performed on every continent and
you know and I had I had many more TV
shows after that so but it wasn't even
about the showers it's about you stand
up at the end yeah that's all this has
been about the 34 year journey you never
stop and I think like if we boil it down
and then that's you know I'm telling
this story in my book I mean you know
everything has been for stand-up comedy
you know I moved to New York I moved to
New York for stand-up I moved to Europe
you know everything cuz you know your
human experiences are where you're the
best comedy material comes from the
truth the life you've lived you know and
so travel in the world moving to Europe
all these things and then I think
ultimately me cuz for four years
partying and I got great stories for my
act you know I did so much of my show is
you know to act stories of excess and
then I think it came to a point where I
knew I could be a better comedian if I
wasn't [ __ ] drunk every night when I
busted my head open in Philadelphia you
know the next day I that is the reason
why I stopped drinking because I thought
you know what was your typical drinking
day well I mean not I'm talking about
what I ran with you I'm talking about
even then you were rock'n'roll always
you know and that's the thing and I have
a club will be able to coordinate yeah
and you get two or three and a shot or
something well yeah then after the show
then that's when the Colombians showed
up he
Hamburger Helper yeah for the booze yeah
um a normal evening would be like you
know like when I busted my head open it
was pretty surprising because it was a
pretty normal evening I had ten pints of
Sierra Nevada and well yeah I do
that was it that was it that that was
that was a Thursday and I'll pass that
you know pass I if I was drinking wine I
would drink well you know if I like if I
wasn't at a club and getting by the
glass I'd drink probably uh you know two
or three bottles maybe sometimes squeeze
out a fourth one you know I love booze
and I've always been able to handle it
and stay up all night you know I was a
[ __ ] tank
how crazy is that I'm so heaviest but
that's not one of my shortcomings like
I'm like a [ __ ] [ __ ] like I like my
little man water even though I stopped
doing the pills and the [ __ ] drinking
and the snort the drinking was never my
problem but I wish I can look a man in
the face I really do all my life there
was a couple years when I was doing it
because I was doing coke and I was
trying to act like [ __ ] Don Johnson
so I would see and try to always get a
drink you know but it's not my forte
it's not my forte to look at me and go
let's go have three beers or a bar and
sit there I don't know what it's never
been in me I wish I could I mean every
once a while man I wake up one day no go
for a [ __ ] cold Heineken well take me
eight days to get that beer
that's how much of a scaredy-cat I am
like when it comes to how long you don't
drink on planes cuz you really die
that's what killed Carrie Fisher that
and this weed the same way that we got
the headache from is the week that
killed Carrie for now I yeah that's the
way she smoked the night before no way
ha no but I wish I was a social drinker
if I could do it again I wish I could
like in the seventies all the TV shows
had bottles with no labels other than
people if you walked in the dang
automatically I didn't even ask you know
Kiki what are you drinking tonight no it
was brown that's all you needed to know
I went I opened up a thing I put three
ice cubes in there I put three fingers
in my handle to you
there was no I'm driving there was no
I'm not I'll have an uber app there was
no I have a meeting in 20 minutes you
[ __ ] drank that thing take top Magoo
like nothing happened you know how how
bad I wish I could do that time runs it
was it would never end me I go on the
walk calmly Club what the [ __ ] what
headliners we could drink whenever you
want I don't know a [ __ ] bar and I'll
sit there at the comedy club and I'll
look at every bottle and analyze it at
the end yo there's nothing I really want
I want anisette like if the you know I
don't know what's an is that what's the
there's a real on the gorilla a nice
yeah I mean Eva why that's so - Oh over
ice that's just delicious I like
Cointreau over ice who drinks Cointreau
only a half a [ __ ] like me three cuatro I
want to buy my friend a friend Jellico
Neely's oh my god a friend Jellico with
a [ __ ] splash too [ __ ] high
Baileys Irish cream and a little [ __ ]
cream and you shake it up with ice cubes
two dollars after nap the only things I
see you might have whipped cream in the
hole you
one night I wanted and they were making
pina coladas and I told the guy give me
a drink
and put some whipped cream on but no
Penguins - I don't know whatever [ __ ]
color but it's weird I could never just
go into a bar with Tom Rhodes and go
give me uh give me a [ __ ] uh do a
Dewar's on the rocks man and ginger
would have beer back and give my friend
whatever the [ __ ] he's drinking and by
the time the bartender gets to you you
already do the [ __ ] the [ __ ] doers
and giving them the class like here go
get another one before the party even
starts like a lot of periods man he's
how you see you know drink Stoli on ice
I just I love booze I love gin and tonic
wine gin and tonics a great with a lot
of Lyman and short yeah for some reason
at all gin and tonic wasn't my [ __ ] but
a short one after and Kent did a couple
blasting coke forget about it I would
tell you the story you wanna hey I also
like Dewar's on the rocks when I was
smoking I don't know what I turned 70 I
think I might have a start having like a
glass of wine every yeah I don't want
you to seven because like I like hanging
out in Paris and Rome and there's
something cool about sitting in a cafe
sipping a glass of wine which I'm not
gonna go back to the [ __ ] staying up
all night normal store going oh yeah
yeah that's I could this nights where I
watched narcosis okay this life's higher
life tired wisdom isn't coming from
[ __ ] doing coke all night no anymore
and we thought it did for a long time
yeah a little [ __ ] will we look at how
wrong we were
it's so weird how sometimes I see people
doing coke on our clothes or the other
shell of that chair when I turn the show
off I like going to your office and
think about what would happen if I ever
do know what like I don't even have a
desire to stick anything how disgusting
is that putting a dollar bill up your
nose that is the most disgusting [ __ ]
thing you could have a [ __ ] doing
your life do you know that you know any
[ __ ] diseases you
from that I had a wart removed in my
nose it had me from what it had to be
from dollars or something something was
in my nose that grew for a long time
like a [ __ ] it's not that wouldn't come
out it was connected I'm gonna line
nobody anyway I love him one of my
aunt's older aunts got hepatitis C years
yeah and she told me um always always
use your own dollar yeah very very
helpful you know their family heirloom
advice to pass down so yeah I'm happy
for you thanks man
you're off the booze you look good let
me give some shoutouts real quick to
some [ __ ] tremendous people your
nephews I I hope they still listen for
the Yale the [ __ ] tip-top and told on
whatever the [ __ ] his name is quali Tony
over there in Vegas don't [ __ ] you
know hold on [ __ ] and don't make
me find that kind of clever dead movie
star bro
Jimmy nunya Anthony J miles B MKULTRA
Rob Marley Ryan McCauley and Alan Alec
and my girl
chichi whether you kidding me or what
anyway and III have a new album out on
iTunes it's called all hey laughter so
just came out like a month ago did you
really want so here I'm saying guys most
people's TV show but it got cancelled
they want to rent grant under a tent
they've got a real estate handed 9 ugly
kids and then told their kids it did
comedy with Joe Rogan but not Tom wrote
for Tom Road there was just a bump in
the road hitting give a [ __ ] he knew his
true calling was stand-up is money and
that's why all that resin I was a born
and put on this are you young comics
that are getting into this because you
think the wall they saw this [ __ ] that
comes with it that don't don't even do
it don't even waste your time just call
it College and go to theater and jump up
and down but if you want to get down
like this other my poor little Stewart's
friend and I only promised immortality
you don't even think like that the
passion to do stand-up
passion to be a fighter the passion for
the Olympics whatever your [ __ ]
passion is you don't look at a [ __ ] a
couch for me in 1998 was the [ __ ]
Four Seasons
it was a yeah like I was sleeping here
the [ __ ] Datsun b210 and I loved it
and to wake up with no chiropractor and
to get back in the car like those triple
runs you have to drive eight hours from
one gig for the next how do you think
you get there way you click your heels
you take a flight
you got a drive so sometimes if a show
start at 7:30 for example I would say
late we're gonna call the [ __ ] hotel
and see if they can check us in at 6:00
a.m. what are you talking about we're
driving after the show so we could sleep
all day you follow me like you did
things like that that's absolutely no
and I understand roughing an island and
that's what I was that's what I said at
the beginning in this is that that was
one of the things that deterred me from
it but I can see now where the like some
of the love came in you guys [ __ ]
love is love whatever you have a passion
for guys don't think about money just
make believe there's no [ __ ] money
involved close your eyes and go into it
and then go this is what I'm going for
if you're good and if you do the [ __ ]
work you're supposed to do the money
will come later I guarantee you but you
gotta clock in every day but Joey my
deadline is for years listen go for 20
go for 20 if you get into something like
this go it's gonna be 20 years before I
[ __ ] people to go I'm gonna give it two
years you know every two years and if I
ain't famous to you one it doesn't work
that way guys you got to put your heart
into this [ __ ] that's all I need to tell
you Lee next time get it together
like I told you people in the beginning
of the show all right it's Valentine
season and you want that muffler to be
fresh just in case you bump into an
important significant other this could
be your wife but you don't want to make
a bad impression with skidmore finger
underwear and yeah [ __ ] smell like
ten dead billy goats
that's why you need to go - hello - she
calm again how old is she
they have a beautiful portable the day
that comes in all colors it takes ten
minutes to install and it'll change your
life you don't have an idea what life is
- you go to the bathroom take the
biggest [ __ ] of your life and then you
just open your legs let that water go
into your muffler you have no idea you
go you gotta watch that ass Joe you
gotta watch that ass that's why y'all
gonna help you calm right now you want
to get far in this life you got to keep
it clean you got to keep it clean you
heard it from the man that's
international
okay international this guy got crabs
and [ __ ] Malaysia who does that do you
have that on your [ __ ] resume anyway
go to hell and you know I got rid of it
[ __ ] [ __ ] badeah what's it called
hello Russia I said I'm gonna hello
pushy and press in sure I get 10% off
your next portable bidet for Valentine's
Day get your grandmother a gift she's 80
here so smells like that
let it die with respect and dignity let
that little old bat die we respect and
dignity gather a portable bidet you
install it it comes in different colors
listen just got a little tissue dot-com
you're gonna love me for this that's
your Valentine's present for your
significant other right impressing
church now I'm giving you 10% off what
are you feeling right now wait what what
is in your heart right now me you're
sitting there looking at me like no
Julian thought that that was the
beginning no there's no beginning to no
exam just ask me hey daughter make sure
you feel good pressure on my head
sometimes
nobody hear you dad correct I just
wanted to make sure you say on tape so
the cops don't company and try to sue me
ten years another sahi and had the bomb
did not touch your head oh my correct I
don't think so okay as long as we all
know that he's going
through this life you did a bong hit
maybe you went the wrong way what do you
feel surprised yeah we're uh in my face
in your face yeah yeah
alright we're gonna call my no no no no
no I don't think so
listen to make a neck brace in the car
we can make this look that I could throw
you off the balcony
no no you'll be fine you'll be fine
let's call 9-1-1 but let me throw you
off the balcony should we collect all of
us a small ten points I will make you
land on your head will land you on your
show if I go to the hospital it's gonna
be the end I can't
a month why'd you take six edibles Lee
either take six edibles I don't know you
don't take a Peter Gammons you take two
edibles you take a few those add up
let's look at look at me look at this
guy
do I even look anything no you took six
I saw you even took later there's
nothing wrong he he probably went that
wholesale sushi place again but gave
that [ __ ] bat blood of the seeds what
you for dinner Jersey Mike's again
really go to Jersey Mike's a couple
times a week and what did you tell Mike
Turkey was beautiful together yeah oh
Jesus Christ I don't know she died
mixing it that's how Belushi died you're
right mixin it up you got to do one of
the other pick a country jackets tightly
you gotta take the number six
we're provolone like six points with
lettuce tomato and [ __ ] onions you
know what that roast beef does to you
don't blame it on the animals you're all
pale and sugars you longer I mean it
differ a little bit before this yeah we
will do another bucket not really
alright cuz the bunk analyst though at
least at the bottom is engaged Jesus
Christ Jesus how you get the heavy you
didn't eat dinner that's what I did you
don't forget people I told you seriously
earlier so I Saturday nights already
sold out so all you got a Sparrow's day
in Friday in Denver I comedy works in
the final week I'm an Alabama and I
thought I loved Matt in the surgery so
don't play no [ __ ] games people all
right I'm having a surgery I'll be
enough no no look never fear uncle
Joey's here you understand
me but anesthesia I go in at nine and
I'm home by 12 o'clock it's fine and I
won't get carsick no more hopefully once
they take the tube out I won't get
carsick so that's the [ __ ] plan
people but before that don't forget the
55th birthday uncle Joey's double nickel
birthday show the 17th and a month at
the ice after small room I think it's
gonna go fast whatever that cheap
it's a Saturday and I work out before I
go to Denver and at least I get to see
some searching church soldiers [ __ ]
my Brown my 55th birthday I get to see
some action I can't get [ __ ] up cuz I
Drive home but you know me will always
when there's a will there's a way
so I'll see you know it'll be 55 years
old out
I just turned 51 I thought in January I
thought I was lucky if I'd made it to 37
Gigi you got anything you want to report
you sure you don't say that no special
report anyway listen to me like I said T
earlier I'm gonna take care you for
Valentine's Day you want to look good
with your significant others Valentine's
Day correct then check out me undies
matching pairs a unique fun gift for you
and your Valentine they're the perfect
balance of comfortable fit and exciting
prints don't spend another Valentine's
Day giving the same old boring gift
check out me on these calm and find the
best match for you you guys know that I
love me undies and I wear them to
jujitsu I love them I believe in them I
loved 100% satisfaction guarantee and
beyond these guarantees you and your
significant other will love your
matching pairs beyond these are the most
comfortable and fun underwear you're
ever wear they're made from the softest
material on earth so this Valentine's
Day get your partner a gift that's for
the both of you order by February 5th ok
at 10 a.m. for free standard shipping so
your gift arrives on time matching pairs
of fun thoughtful and they're
comfortable gift you can share with your
significant other
man sipping on wine looking at each
other and you have your hand on her
breast
and she's massaging your thigh and you
have the coolest underwear on the earth
and you have to live the diet that the
lights dim the cows sexy oh look we're
matching on this with that little fun
your wife looks good in and you you're a
little [ __ ] athletic cut who gives a
[ __ ]
take a chance come on visited me and
these are the best underwear out there
and what I'm going to do see you get 20%
off your matching pair free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee go to beyond
these comms last Joey again that's me of
these comms last Joey this will be the
best Valentine's gift that you'll never
give her all right
or give him start matching your bottom
half to your better half go to me undies
comm slash Joey right now and why be
alone again I'm hooking you up I'm
getting your muffler washed and buffed
and I'm getting your sexy underwear why
are you gonna be alone you can't get to
know somebody just by looking at their
pinky that's the problem all right
if you're trying online dating chances
are you've run into lazy text messages
and just that in conversations and
random matches that don't turn into
dates let me tell you some Lee how great
is eHarmony it's great it's uh it really
takes the time to like when you sign up
it takes a little bit of time but it's
really matches you a little person and
you another time you were out of the
dating services correct correct I've had
a TR B's the way to go absolutely it's
the best one out there
it's Yami's unlike money I love dating
it's unlike many other online dating
site er me take steps that other dating
sites don't in order to find you a more
compatible match they're built to help
you find lasting meaningful relationship
not a shallow hook-up site alright they
have helped over a million people find
that perfect match he harmony uses years
and years of science data and
psychological research to send you the
right matches it also brings compatible
people together that's what the Army is
about there plenty of hook-up site
if that's what you want go for it that's
not what you want right now we the
Church of what's happening now can get a
free month with a harmony where we sign
up for a three-month subscription enter
my code Church CH you are CH at checkout
all right stop waiting and start your
journey to a satisfying meaningful
relationship it can be fun to play
around online dating apps but when
you're ready to fall in love I mean
really really fall in love with somebody
and have a meaningful relationship
there's only one app that's built to
bring your real love and that's he
harmony come see
harmony calm and see how they can change
your life alright come see he harmony
and see how they can change your life
go to eHarmony calm and get started at
the code Church and let's get your love
ya started alright
I want to thank you harmony I want to
thank me on these a little thang hello -
she for a tremendous January I'll see
you guys next week February I want to
thank my man Tom Rhodes Thank You
Jillian off you better go see him love
him respect zero Tom Rhodes calm how
much that net Tom Rhodes dotnet for
future dates listen have a great weekend
I love you guys stay black see at the
ice house hit Utley